j'ai l'impression que tout s'écroule au
niveau de mon lesbienne est politique
l'espoir si ça peut arriver à tout le
monde d'avoir une rechute
vous étiez spectaculaire dans le rôle de
marie josée une militante communiste
lesbiennes politique que dans c'est
comme ça que je t'aime en prépare à cet
entretien ce refus des marais j'ai
vraiment réalisé à quel point vous étiez
décidés à faire ce métier la comédienne
parce que vous êtes fils d'un
contremaître dans une imprimerie
oui votre roman travaillé chez bell mais
à 14 ans vous vous avez décidé bas c'est
ce que je vais faire un livre
alors d'où elle est venue cette passion
pour le jeu bienvenue à parce que je
suis allé au collège marie-clarac est un
collage pour femmes puis quand quand on
a fait du théâtre à l'école va
évidemment les rôles devait être comblé
par par tout le monde les personnes
voulaient jouer les garçons puis chez
moi j'étais très à ces petits mais en
fait je suis toujours mais bon ben je
vais je c'était pour monde c'était pour
jouer don juan de molière je suis bon
ben je vais le faire personne ne voulait
le faire mais je savais pas que ça
allait être pour moi un éveil incroyable
j'écris cela fait du bien
j'aime diverti le site web est chanceuse
d'avoir eu un appel vers une vocation
c'était comme fait clair pour moi que
c'était ce que je voulais faire c'était
un seul os est vraiment ah oui c'était
super fort c'est vraiment quelque chose
que j'ai faite aux mondiaux mais c'est
ma place je vais être sur scène et
défendez des personnages je lis pas ce
dont il s'agit
courriel une évasion le cinéma ça vous
permet de vaincre cette gêne
oui absolument elle est toujours là
quand même cher je reste chance
quelqu'un de timide mais c'est pour ça
que ce qui m'intéresse c'est de jouer
des personnages et non pas maintenant
devenir une animatrice ou une
personnalité publique qui tu sais pas
c'est pas ma personnalité mais donc moi
si je suis si je sers l'écriture de un
liquide sur d'un rôle ben je vais être
je me sentir donc pour vous donner des
entrevues c'est pas nous sommes à votre
tasse de thé il sait vous préférez dans
le personnage d'adam lang zaccardo
exactement oui absolument pee wee ça me
rend nerveuse des entrevues puis les
apparitions publiques je suis très très
discrète sur les réseaux sociaux
j'aime à ce parti surtout
tous
et g
j'essaie de me respecter là dedans parce
qu'on dirait qu aujourd'hui on sait que
on ait de la pression
les acteurs il faut absolument t être
sûr plein plateforme s'autopromouvoir
viens moi ça me parle pas du tout à des
questionnements c'est ça ça vous est à
la solde d'intérêts ce monde non ça
mettait un sport beaucoup non denses et
paillasse une belle visibilité belle
famille oui des fois ça peut être bien
pour faire de la promotion surtout d'un
projet si je vais en face surtout dans
cette idée là c'est pas parce qu'un
projet mais telle idée de faut que ce
soit visible que je crois qu'on voit ben
j'en vois jamais prendre le pari d'être
d'être anonyme
waouh c'est plus simple est ce parce que
je suis réservé c'est juste que j'ai pas
de jugement là dessus c'est juste que ça
me ressemble
j'aime ce les acteurs qui sont qui sont
plus anonyme parce qu on dirait que -
même les connaît plus on adhère à la
proposition je sais pas ce que je
préfère me dit que l'acteur ânonner mais
vous le plus
[Rires]
je pense maintenant à sébastien ricard
qu'on voit peu dans ces choses là mais
je trouve que tu as une belle démarche
choqué parce que moi qui m'inspire de
aia ont fait un petit peu mais n'en fait
pas trop et puis on connait pas trop de
choses sur lui puis on sait que c'est
vraiment plus les rôles qui sont
marquantes et le concernant que je sais
pas ce qui fait ses fans semaine par ok
vous avez vraiment multiplié les rôles
au théâtre mais vous vous êtes fait
connaître surtout dans la série yamaska
ça a été le tournant pour vraiment
propulsez votre carrière au niveau
télévisuel je pense que oui siegel si un
peu à peu des couches et 131 yamaska
c'était une super belle aventure ça a
duré six ans pour moi j'avais de la
chance parce que j'avais juste trois
jours de tournage avec ce rôle qui
aimait mon agente et comme est ce parce
que si tu fais ces trois jours la prêter
brûlé dans la série tu peux plus revenir
sur ben moi j'ai besoin d'argent puisque
l'euro l'iphone fait que je vais je vais
y aller j'ai été chanceuse parce que
lyon ait mille personnages
ils m'ont gardé pendant six ans j'ai pu
faire un espèce de duos qui était
chouette avec rené richard cyr et sa
nouvelle rencontre pour moi aussi
c'était moi ça vous interpelle qu'est ce
qu'il vient vous chercher dans cette
forme d'ordre way le cinéma c'est
peut-être là requis le plus le plus
prennent moins encore plus quel théâtre
je tairai qui avait pas d'accord
ferez quoi
[Applaudissements]
comme je disais j'ai une nature un peu
timide puis peut-être un peu intériorisé
parfois je suis réservé et puis donc le
cinéma c'est plus simple pour moi parce
que c'est une émotion puis tu fais juste
là jaillir un petit peu puis s exprime
ses spas comme mon théâtre au faux tu
parles l'intérieur aussi mais il faut
que tu déploies le petit jusqu'à la
dernière rangée en arrière la salle
techs et c'est un exercice qui différent
sur le fil des marées
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup juste dire
getinge accès pris aucune sanction dans
les rangs on sait que c'est juste parce
que c'est moi qu'il est venu là chef